based on some of our past votes i'd say
probably if they wanted it to pass they
probably ought to let us know what it's
about
maybe we should demand something in
return
[Music]
it could
be know roger yeah rogers has been doing
all right these days and i fight hard
for rochester you know but
you know we couldn't use the parking
garage
so go ahead and build it
so can milford
the
winner so when you look at just a good
guy
when you look at the transition
that portsmouth has had in their
downtown
and how dover is mimicking some of that
and it is now starting to happen in
rochester
where
people who are building apartments are
getting
more and more
interested in
you know places like downtown in
rochester
but if you go up
to rochester yes
right near that was actually the first
first
next scheduled
opportunity
gps well
gps may have given you the old location
took me off
and had me make a right hand turn
instead of the left
closed captioning not available
good morning and
i am
good morning
and uh welcome to our uh
special fiscal committee
committee meeting today
to
talk about the items that were
tabled
as well as
a briefing on the
annual comprehensive financial report
and i am especially looking forward to
that
uh
i think that
will be pleasantly surprised from
all that i have read
so
uh
fis-21357
was withdrawn
by gopher
and so we will not be
uh discussing that
uh the next one is fis 21
365. madam chair
i would move to remove 365 from the
table
do i have a second
i will second that or okay thank you
senator d'alessandro
okay
uh could we have the uh
folks that are
oh yes i guess we do
yeah yeah
okay 365.
okay
uh those in favor of removing
fis 21 365
from the table please raise your hand
one two three four five six
okay seven two
three
thank you
all right the item is removed thank you
okay um
when we tabled this we had asked um
we didn't feel that we had
sufficient information to
understand
um
what we were actually
planning to do with this money
so
um denise uh submitted to us a um
a very excellent list of
all of the items that vital records
collects
and the
rsas
that we as a body have passed
to
require that collection
so
and um
so i guess that uh
are there
additional questions
that anyone has
regarding this
particular fis
okay
since there are no additional questions
oh you do okay go ahead
it's not really a question thank you
madam chair it's a comment i just want
the members to know i've
received approval to file a late bill
for a study committee to look at
the amount of
birth information that goes from the
hospitals and the mother to the
secretary of state
and um
that
bill is in the process of being signed
off on
so that
we will have an opportunity to discuss
it and
that my three co-sponsors sit on this
committee
okay okay oh okay well thank you for
that i appreciate it
senator guida thank you madam chair uh
to the hhs contingent
uh
i'm under of the understanding that some
years ago
vital records was housed in hhs and then
was subsequently moved to the department
of state can you share some light on
yes that's true and if so why or why
that
that move took place
i'll start with that thank you senator
gaivan for the record patricia tilley
director of public health um thank you
for that question so i was but a baby
when that happened it was a long time
ago in the early 2000s that that moved
over um so i wasn't privy to the
information at that time but at one
point it was housed within um hhs and
worked closely with all of our
informatics like um vital records is
housed in almost every other state in
the country within a department of
health i think my colleagues from
secretary of state might have some
additional information about the
rationale for that move
and i we're not prepared to answer that
i didn't know we're going to go into the
history of
the move so i i can get back to the
committee with the findings but um one
of the things that i would like to say
is that
many times vital records is looked at as
vital statistics and health statistics
but that's very
you know it is a big part of what we do
but it's also not only what we do
and so um
records are held under the secretary of
state many records for this state
and um i
coming from the town clerk so i worked
as a town clerk
in the town clerk's office for 32 years
in the town of guilford and i know the
town clerk's association was behind the
move so that the focus could be on
the vital records portion of it
because we do a lot of servicing of
other state agencies um the general
public
and um
we're you know we're involved with
immigration
it goes much deeper than public health
and so i think i could um put together
some information
for you based on
what we do
and if i could just follow up that um we
have worked in partnership since that
change and we've worked at a um both in
statute there's a partnership listed out
but just collegially we work in
partnership every single day we can't in
the department of health do our work
without vital statistics
yeah yes go ahead thank you madam chair
so is there any formal mou or
yes okay that's defined then thank you
okay
are there any further questions
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair i we we we
heard some testimony about vital records
being a division of secretary of state a
couple months ago in this committee
i i don't recall
exactly how formal the data requests are
from when
dhhs asks for access to vital records
data
and um you know and but i'm i remember
the impression that there's essentially
a firewall between vital records and
and the public health people um that
and that firewall
has some formal procedures to get beyond
it and get access to the data
would you please uh remind me remind the
committee
of the formality
of which it takes somebody in public
health to get access to vital records
data for a particular study
great thank you
thank you representative i don't know if
um i was trying to follow your question
if you want to follow the data from um
department of state to public health or
you just want to understand a little bit
of how in public health we determine
that uh to clarify the question i'm i'm
curious about the formality of which the
public health people ask for access to
vital statistics data so i'm imagining
in the old world we would do a form that
would have all the data we wanted access
to with a description of why we wanted
it and that it would go over to vital
statistics so that they could
independently assure that that was a
valid
request you know i'm i'm wondering about
the formality at which we get access to
data so we have a formal data governance
and data stewardship process that we use
to identify who should have access to
that data um the vital records data sits
within the
through our mou and please correct me if
i'm wrong denise through that mou the um
data moves from secretary of state's
office into the department of health and
human services and it's housed within
our ebi our elect
our um
warehouse our data warehouse which is
what i used to call it it sits within
that data warehouse and then for an
individual dhhs staff member to have
access to that data warehouse they need
to be having a particular role so again
we have a governance and a stewardship
program so they may have a particular
role that allows them or if they need it
for a specific purpose that gets worked
through our governance process um behind
me i have um chadwichala who is the head
of our informatics section and she takes
the lead role in ensuring in protecting
that data so that only those who have
authorized access can can get it
thank you
yes senator rosenwald sorry could um
could you clarify for us please if
the division of vital
records or statistics
um
is either a hipaa covered entity
or has a signed hipaa business associate
contract with the department of health
and human services
i think our mou
does
say that that we will have a hipaa
that we all meet hipaa requirements it's
it is part of our mou
i'm sorry was is is it a
hipaa business associate
contract also yeah so i i mean obviously
the department of health and human
services is a covered entity and has
that and so when we we through our mou
all of our work has to be within that
environment
my question was about the
division of vital records not
department of health and human services
i'm sorry
perhaps we could
rephrase it to say
that she didn't know
okay
uh
i know that we meet hipaa requirements
if that's what the question is
well
and that's
where i was going is that
in statute there are strict requirements
on who can get certain data
being a genealogist
i cannot get
data from anyone who isn't
75 in
population records and older than that
if it's not this is not an open record
could you just summarize some of the
policies that you have maybe that would
satisfy senator rosenwald and
so that she would understand
so are you asking about
the general public
being able to see
certain documentations
are you talking about
staff members in general
just a minute
yes please uh it's
who has access okay um
and is that access identifiable down to
an individual or
you know those kind of things are the
things that
are protected by hipaa
and
you know
certainly i'm sure that the senator
wants
um you know assurance that
that we're not violating hipaa even
though we may not
have it in some way thank you
i think um catherine cheney's here from
our i.t department and she can probably
explain um the tracking and the
different things that we have within our
software system
and not everybody in the department has
access to everything it depends on their
role
if that's what you're looking for
catherine yeah
i what i'm hearing is um that
there needs to be clarification on the
um
specifically what i'm hearing is medical
information in regards to personally
identifying information and is that
information available to
other people i've also heard that do we
have a hipaa compliant a person
or some type of assigned business
hipaa compliant person on staff
those are the two
things that i've heard the first
question is that
our data is
like
what
trisha had said that is protected by
roles we have roles in our system
and that is one of the
the you know stellar upgrades of the
system is that only certain people can
see these records within our own
departments and then every day
these records specifically the
ones we're talking about for dhhs the
death and birth records are
put into the data warehouse where they
have access to all the information the
externally facing
files
never files never in web specifically
are used for statistics and only numbers
are put into that system and for
genealogy that would be part of the
research area in a different
a different area you wouldn't use any of
our system files so anything that's
externally facing is non-identifiable
just mostly numbers
um and then we do not have i don't think
we have a hyper-compliant person on
staff i do know we have a nasologist and
we are one of the few states lucky
enough to have a nasologist who can code
uh causes of death and understands what
that what that really is
again that each staff member has access
to everything it is role-based very
similar to dhhs
where it's based on the individual's
need based on their work so
for instance if somebody's working just
in depth and they don't have any need to
be in birth we identify it
through approval through the director
and also um they're role based in the
computer system to begin with so they
they can't get to certain items
thank you uh rep senator guida thank you
madam chair i think the nexus or the the
condensed version of the question is
is the department of state division of
vital records
required either through the mou or a
associate business agreement
to be compliant with hipaa
yes we are compliant with hipaa we are
required
with everything that we do
okay are there any further questions
representative edwards
uh if you'll allow i have a question for
senator rosenwald may i ask her a
question
okay accept a question
so so i i'm a co-sponsor on your your
bill
so i'm just curious
since you brought it up
uh how does the fact that that bill has
been submitted
how does that does that influence your
view on whether we should approve or
disapprove this request today
no
thank you
okay
are there any further
questions
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
oh yes i need a motion
senator d'allesandro moves do i have a
second
365.
365 motion to approve representative
edwards yes
clerk voces representative irf no
representative walner
senator daniels yes
senator gray yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald
no
senator d'allesandro yes
representative umberger yes
madam sure the vote is eight yes to no
with the vote being eight in favor and
to oppose the uh
the motion passes
thank you thank you very much
uh we now turn to um
fisc 321-371
that's a request from the
department of health and human services
it is currently tabled okay i have a
motion from
representative walner
and a second from representative
rosenwald
okay
uh oh welcome back
are there any questions for hhs on this
fis
sorry madam chair do you just have to
take a motion on removing it from the
table martin you just need to take that
oh okay i'm sorry that's okay
thank you for keeping me straight okay
all those in favor of taking this off
the table please raise your hand
seven in favor
and three opposed
okay
are there any questions for hhs
on
this
fis 3
21-371
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair um
so i i just have uh
just a general concern that i think has
been consistent over several meetings
now and that is
that
in the previous budget year we
under funded i think arguably
underfunded i.t enhancements
and this this budget term
with the state money and the federal
money
uh we've opened up a massive spigot of
cash to go towards uh i.t
and what i would like to see at some
point
is
a summary by the department a portfolio
analysis of all of the projects going on
although the people that need to be
hired or who have been hired
so that we we have a sense
that in the aggregate this this money
that we're allocating in
each's
is in the portfolio level
being responsibly managed and i suspect
it is
but um and just not it's not an answer
for today it's a heads up
that i've asked hhs oversight to make it
an agenda item so you've got a couple
months but
i i really i really am lost in the
portfolio of not seeing the portfolio as
we approve these each's
okay we can um figure out a way to do
that what i would mention is i don't
believe there's an i.t project
associated with this item
i i'm sorry i i'm seeing
data modernization am i on the wrong one
yeah i am on the wrong one
all right so i was on the wrong one and
that was really embarrassing that's okay
it's okay but you had us reading it as
well yeah but my comment was generic
enough that i think you'll still run
with it thank you i understood that
thank you
okay are there any further are there any
further questions
seeing none i will uh
okay thank you thank you for keeping me
out of trouble
do i have a do i have a second
okay and uh
representative walner seconds
will the clerk please call the roll
yes
on 371 representative edwards yes
court votes yes representative irf no
representative walner
senator daniels
no
senator gray
yes
senator guida no
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
chair the vote is seven yes three no
the vote being seven in favor and three
opposed fis 21 371
is approved
thank you very much
we now move to fis 21
389.
adam charlie
move to remove it from the table second
okay uh removed from the table by
representative
emmerich and seconded by representative
irf
are there questions from the committee
madam chair just the motion on removing
oh sorry
okay thank you i got it i keep
forgetting that okay all those in favor
of removing
21 389 from the table please raise your
hand
uh looks like nine to one is that
correct
you're opposed
okay
votes nine to one
the item is removed from the table
now i will try are there any questions
from
the committee on this fis-21389
representative wallner
thank you uh madam chair
i think you need to yeah bring it a
little closer thank you
get better yeah um i was not here in
december so i wasn't here when the item
was tabled but
i would
like to understand better
if you're having a hard time hiring
and you have vacancies
explain to me about why you don't have
excess money in your
budget at this point to pay for hiring
people and
just a little bit follow up on that
it's hard right now to hire people for
any job
so i'd like to understand a little more
about where you think the we're going to
find these people and where this agency
will find them
and why is it only a seven month
contract
so i will answer the first question and
then um turn it over to the commissioner
director ribson so karen rounds chief
financial officer dhhs
um so i did distribute to uh the lba the
state fiscal year 22 budget which also
included 1920 and 21 at the bottom
and i hope that that was distributed to
the committee
the
total budget appropriated for sysc was
10.4 million which included general
funds and
other and federal funds
part of what we budgeted um for in
fiscal year 22 and 23 was
funds from the state of vermont because
we do have a contract with them to
take kids from the state of vermont at
sysc
what we have found now being six months
through the year which is when we
typically are able to do the first set
of reliable projections is that the
revenue from vermont is going to be less
we're predicting about
a little over a million dollars less
and the way that
um
the the law is written
we must write down the appropriation if
we're not anticipating the revenue
so we are anticipating writing down
um
by that a million or so dollars leaving
us a budget of about 9.5 million
the expenditures so far this year are
about 5.2 million there's encumbrances
that are a little over a half a million
um we have spent um about
277 thousand dollars
in overtime of staff that are not
employed by sysc so employed um by
elsewhere and dcyf so we should transfer
that expense to sysc um which is about
277 thousand
dollars um there is a slight addition to
the budget uh because of the raise that
will happen on seven one
uh we are anticipating having to make
some additional payouts when people
retire for about fifty six thousand
dollars
leaving our expense projections um for
the rest of the year around 4.2 million
what i would also mention is in the
expenditures already to date
is
303 000
of
retirement payouts from reductions in
force that we did at the beginning of
the fiscal year to meet this budget
so with that we're expecting total
expenditures to be 10.3 million which
you'll note is less than the total
appropriation that was given for sysc
but because of that revenue write down
we actually have about an 800 000
shortfall in the sysc budget so in
addition to these funds to support this
contract we will be coming back to the
committee with a transfer transferring
funds from elsewhere in the department
to cover that eight hundred thousand
dollars
so
the budget is less than what total
budget is less than what is appropriated
but because that revenue right down we
don't have enough funds in the budget
so i can speak to why the contract is a
short contract this really is a bridge
contract to our transition contract
we've talked now for several years about
finding a replacement facility for sysc
and i don't think there's ever been a
time in the past where the department
has been as committed as it is now to
closing sysc and moving those kids into
a more clinical model um it isn't just
sysc
that we made that commitment to if you
recall a couple years ago we committed
to
closing the laconia drf which had been
open for 30 years and everyone said we
could never close it and we closed it in
about a year
we're in the same place with sysc but
between now and when we build
renovate
buy another building
we need to provide safe level of
staffing for the kids cobit has required
us to open quarantine units we have more
kids on two to one and one to one
all of these
were unknown at the time that the budget
was developed for sysc so it's it's
caused an escalation in our personnel
costs we're not able to hire for a
variety of reasons
this contractor has serviced other areas
of the state have been very successful
in getting temporary workforce for other
areas of dhhs and other areas of the
state so we're confident that they'll be
able to do it
um so like i said it's a bridge we need
we need transition time
between
making the commitment to close it and
actually closing it and we need to
provide safe
a safe environment in that time if we're
not able to provide a safe environment
there are there are alternatives none of
them are excuse me none of them are good
for the kids none of them are good for
the state that includes sending kids out
of state
and i don't mean massachusetts or
vermont i'm talking far away out of
state because they don't have beds
either
sending kids with mental health
issues to emergency room boarding
which is not a great place to be
right now because of covid and the
hospitals are overwhelmed so we're
trying everything we can to care for
these kids in place until we have that
replacement facility
up and ready to go
[Music]
senator guy do you have a question yes
madam sure thank you
so
if we don't hire these people
will we have
our kids going out of state
if we
if we don't find additional temporary
staff or hire our own staff which we
haven't been successful in
there is a good possibility that if we
continue to lose staff or our population
goes up or becomes more acute that we
will either have to send kids out of
state to a detention facility out of
state
send them to the
the kids that have mental health issues
send them to the emergency room and have
them board there
there there will have to be other
alternatives to care that are not
in the best interest of the kids and if
i can just add to that that will also
come with additional cost so i would
have to come back with an item to pay
for that
you have a follow-up yes madam chair
are you able to quantify in fairly
specific terms what the cost of one
out-of-state placement is
these high-level facilities tend to cost
somewhere around seventeen hundred
dollars a day
would you mind stating your name for the
right i'm sorry joe ripson director of
dcyf thank you
thank you
senator rosenwald
just for comparison what is our daily
rate we were charging vermont wasn't
like 1600 i think it's about 1700 i
think it might be just under
so
the cost i
a child at sysc is
about the same as sending them out of
state
it's comparable but if you don't totally
close down sysc you still have to manage
an essential basic operation and as
we've spoken about in the past
one of the big challenges fiscally with
sysc is we've long gone below the census
that makes the economies of scale make
sense we had a lot of conversations
about that in this
falls
committee to study the closure and
replacement of sysc
so
sending kids out of state is unlikely to
get every child out of sysc there's not
there aren't a lot of options out there
right now we're having difficulty
placing kids out of state for other
reasons and there aren't local like
neighboring states that are willing to
take these kids so i'm not even sure
that that's a viable option but that
would be the next
the next thing we would try and would
probably be worse for the kids that we
have there now thank you are there any
further questions
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair and um
commissioner um
you you
you said something that got me wondering
you mentioned that we're still trying to
look at
three basic options uh renovate remodel
i forget what the third one was but but
that doesn't matter to my question what
it leaves me with the impression that
here we are in january and a lot of
people are expecting um the solution to
be available
in april of next year where that's you
know very close
and so um i would like to know from you
two things
uh is is are you is are you
strategically leaning one way or another
on how to do the replacement part on the
sununu closure uh and what are the odds
in your opinion
of us having it done
before the end of this budget year
june 30 2000 whatever 23.
the
it's unlikely that we will close doors
of sysc prior to june 30 of 2023.
i think that we will be well on our way
to closing doors like
whether that's in construction for
renovation or building i think that will
be well underway but i don't know that
we would be ready to close doors by june
2023 it just depends on construction
schedules and things like that
um i we're still looking at the options
for property
the restrictions on the land in
manchester there's a lot of legal issues
that are around those different items
that that we have to investigate before
we
come with uh for certain recommendations
now the we formed a commission last
summer that submitted a report to the
legislative commission around our
recommendations the legislative
commission then submitted their own
recommendations around what they thought
they would do i think
we're going to find
what we end up doing to be somewhere a
combination of both of those things
i'm not leaning one way or the other i'm
really waiting for legal to kind of
um really investigate what my options
are on the different state properties uh
what we need legislatively to make a
change what we need budget-wise to to
make that change to fund those projects
that's the phase it's in right now
follow-up
uh so it sounds like you you all have to
come back at some point to give us um a
budget proposal to get you all the way
through the budget year because i don't
believe your budget was built to take
you there
and i'm just curious when you might be
coming back with with what what what the
real financial need is to get us through
the budget term
so
yeah it's a difficult
question to answer for sure because it
we do
have to have a sense of what the plan
moving forward is to know
um
what we might need but i i think it'll
be next fiscal year before we come back
because we'll need to
figure out where the vermont funds are
at that point um we'll need the way that
the appropriation was done for sysc it
was just a lump sum appropriation so we
have to go through and figure out um you
know all the different class lines what
the employment looks like at that point
and and then figure out how much we'll
need for funds so it won't be until the
state that state state fiscal year 23
begins thank you
are there
representative
daniels senator daniels sorry thank you
um
i think last last we had heard reported
from you there were only one or two
uh youth from vermont
how many did we lose
i think overall we've had a total of
seven since the contract started over a
year ago
at this point we have zero we've
actually had to decline
requests five requests to take kids over
the last couple months because our
staffing situation was so tough that we
couldn't handle additional youth within
the facility
okay so
the
the reduction didn't take place all at
once is that correct
i'm sorry
you you mentioned we've lost seven over
the last year no it's not about losing
them so the way that the contract is
written is that um vermont makes a
request to us to take a child um on
their behalf so it's not that we had
seven there and then it's slowly reduced
it's sort of a one-off situation they
call when they have a need
um so what director ripson is saying is
that we've had seven different children
there since the contract began for
varying periods of time not for the
entire period of time and that since
then they've made additional requests um
and we've not been able to um
to meet their requests because of
staffing okay so what's the expectation
in the revenue that you expected to get
revenue from vermont
but
yeah so our expectation was that we
would have somewhere between one and two
kids for the entire year okay
um
what is our population now
today's census is 14.
i do have i think representative
umberger asked last time to get you know
a snapshot of whatever week has looked
like so i could share that if folks are
interested
and and i believe that when you went
through the budget you probably
budgeted for 18.
no we were
we were budgeting thinking you'd have on
average 12 because that's what our
average daily census had been
but there's a difference in the needs of
the kids that we're serving right now
particularly over the past two months
and that we've had a high number of high
acuity kids
who we've tried to move into
high level
psychiatric residential treatment
facilities or acute care facilities but
because those facilities are so
overwhelmed
it's been a long it takes a long time
with a long time on a waiting list to
get kids into those facilities so kids
have been who are very high need that
often require two to one supervision are
staying in sysc for a longer period of
time than they typically would because
the ability to move them on has been cut
off by the children's mental health
creation crisis nationwide
so
in the
directions that we were given
on trying to find a replacement for
sununu
where we were told that you needed space
for 18.
why would you budget for 12
when you're telling the committee that
you needed space for 18
because the the request for space for 18
was not just about having 18 beds but
having the flexibility for when kids go
higher and when kids go lower the census
has varied between as low as 6 and as
high as i think 16 over the past
12 months
so you have flexibility you have
movement in there and it changes every
day every week
you also have needs to separate children
based on gender based on court orders
based on their individual clinical needs
so when you have fixed space on a fixed
unit
you can't necessarily use every single
bed right if you have one unit that has
six beds for six girls but you only have
two girls in the facility and you have
eight girls and eight boys in the
facility you're not able to maximize all
of the building space so the
conversation around a new facility for
18 beds was largely related to the
flexibility to meet the discrete needs
of youth and have you spread
appropriately throughout the facility
not that we anticipated having the
facility full at 18 at all times
if i can just add to that we also look
to budget conservatively conservatively
so we budgeted on the average rather
than the maximum
we could certainly budget on the maximum
and then lapse more funds but that's not
we try not to do that okay was i wrong
in
i guess assuming that you were budgeting
for the worst case scenario
um i mean there are certain there are
certainly times that i budget for the
worst case scenario because i'm
expecting the worst case scenario and in
this case it's based on trends we felt
pretty comfortable budgeting on the
average
okay
and
you know the similar question with your
staffing level um
what what were you figuring on a ratio
when you when you put the budget in
so
the the main staff we're talking about
here are the youth counselors is the
direct care staff there's also a lot of
other staff within the facility
which which largely hit that economies
of scale issue i spoke to speaking about
earlier whether you have one kid or 10
kids in the building 12 kids in the
building 15 kids a building you need
nurses you need clinicians you need
mental health psychiatrists
psychologists doctors that are coming
out you need all of those things
regardless of the level of kids
but the youth counselors which is what
this request is about is the one that's
most dynamic
you typically need
if you don't have anything extraordinary
happening
one youth counselor and system to
monitor central control without somebody
sitting there to monitor central control
which has all the cameras and access and
control over all the doors there's no
way for people to move through the
building so you need one youth counselor
in that space and typically you want two
youth counselors on every open unit
because you don't want one one youth
counselor with multiple kids
just a high risk situation do that staff
aren't comfortable we don't think it's
safer appropriate
so you often typically would have three
units open one for girls two for boys
some with boys with higher level needs
boys who have court orders that have to
be separated because they were involved
in the same type maybe in the same
criminal activity where they have you
know issues with each other or they're
involved in in different gangs or
something like that you have to keep
them separated so you typically on an
average day with nothing extraordinary
happening you need seven youth
councillors in the building to make the
building run
this hasn't been an average time since
the start of covid we typically have a
young person who's sitting in our
medical unit
having a
covet test and awaiting results before
they can be moved into the rest of the
facility when a young person is assigned
to medical for any reason a youth
counselor has to sit with them in
medical to make sure that they're safe
and they're cared for the nursing staff
aren't appropriate to do that and the
nursing staff are running around the
building taking care of everybody else
in the building
then when you have situations like we've
had particularly high levels of over the
past month or so where you have youth
who have a two-to-one or one-to-one
supervision that incrementally adds the
needs for more staff
we had a young person in there recently
who was who had made multiple suicide
attempts required a two-to-one
supervision for well over a month even
overnight
because the moment that that youth was
left alone they would actively try to
hurt themselves and we needed to have
people there to make sure that didn't
happen
those types of scenarios have been
compounding towards towards the end of
this you know current coveted period
with the mental health system unable to
take these kids and that's what's
driving a lot of this
so the staffing that we
that we require really to be safe to
cover all of those shifts and that
flexibility each day depending on youth
needs is about 47 youth counselors in
the building that's what we're budgeted
for we currently have 30 working in the
building and i actually received notice
from three more in the past few weeks
that they're leaving
thank you
senator d'alessandro
thank you madam chair uh
joe
just from my standpoint i've re i read
this last graph of the uh the request
and it says the funds will be used to
enter into a contract with the health
care staffing agency to provide 18
temporary staff for the period of seven
weeks
given today's
economy
where are you going to where you're
going to get a staffing agency and what
happens if you can't find them
with a staffing agency what does that
leave us at this point in time so i'm
and the commissioner could speak to this
too she has a governor and counsel but
the staffing agency that we actually we
already have gnc approval on the
contract but it's not funded so it's not
moved forward pending the action in this
committee that's what the staffing
agency called maxim which has had a lot
of success within the state they've
actually already identified a number of
staff that are ready to start training
next week
um
but it's pending the action of this
committee
good for the
chair yes
but we're going to pay dearly for the
staff is that correct
the
this is a request that is for a little
over a hundred thousand dollars in our
funds to pay for the staffing contract i
think that somewhere the staffing agency
is you know the total contract value is
running hundred thousand dollars in
change for 18 staff
thank you
and senator rosenwald
i thought i was following this but
this request would bring you up to like
50 youth counselors and we're budgeted
for 47 so i don't understand again now
why the money is not within the current
appropriation we're budgeted for 47
youth councillors we currently have
about 30 three more have given their
notice
this contract is for 18 because we're
anticipating we'd still have
turnover and dynamic situations with
hiring our own staff
as
cfo rounds explained the problems with
the budget have to do with the
decline the declining revenue from the
vermont contract
and the
unexpected or unbudgeted payouts for
staff that retired when we went through
the last round of
restructuring staff as a result of the
budget cut at the start of this state
fiscal year we reduced 26 positions as a
result of that a lot of those staff
rather than be reassigned chose to
retire and when staff retire from state
service they get a payout for their for
their sick time etc that hit our budget
was not something that we that we were
anticipating at the time that that
budget was crafted
so there's a couple things and the high
overtime usage
what i would hope is that if we're
successful if this contract works and we
get folks in that the overtime demand
will go down drastically there's you'll
look in the budget that was distributed
there's a lot of overtime going out
right now
which costs a lot more than even the
staffing contract would
typically we're paying juvenile
probation officers and now we even have
cpsws going in there to work overtime
because it's so desperate
and those folks are making a lot more
than even the staffing agency is getting
paid when they're working overtime hours
following yes thank you so given that
the department is
looking to move to more of a treatment
focused model with the new facility
um and we are going to stop using the
parole officers
it hopefully
is
is the department or the division able
to commit to
training
these
uh temporary youth counselors in a more
treatment-oriented model than we've
gotten from parole officers
yeah and we've we've already started
that work although it's not complete
we've started moving into a model called
pbis at the at the moment i'm not
remembering what the acronym stands for
but our psychiatrist or psychologist
that's working down there has started
implementing that already the idea is to
start to move folks into the direction
of being clinically oriented
while we're in the process of moving
towards a new facility we also intend to
relook at those sjds change training and
education requirements and all of those
things to make sure that those staff are
actually the right staff to do this more
clinically oriented mental health
oriented treatment that we expect of
them
but that hasn't been the historical
model as you and many people know that's
the transition phase we're in the staff
that come in
the attempts that come in are going to
be trained
with the same things that we're training
our current yc's on which do include
training of things like pbis
the escalation strategies and things
like that to continue the movement
towards a clinically based model but
that's as i said that's a work in
progress
are there any further questions
represented waldman
thank you
so the 846
will pay
hopefully you'll be able to recruit and
pay
18 additional staff
for seven months and that will cover the
846 thousand dollars will cover their
wages during that time
what if they only recruit
nine
let's say they are only able to recruit
nine then will you expend only four
hundred and some thousand
of the contract yeah the way the
contract is structured it's a it's an
hourly rate per hour worked by temp
employee
so there's nothing paid if nobody works
and if everybody works every shift it's
it's the maximum
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a
motion to move the item thank you
senator guida second seconded by
representative edwards
i did better that time
so
will the clerk please call the roll
yes ma'am chair uh
on 371 representative edwards yes
corporate chess representative erf yes
representative walner
senator daniels
yes
senator gray yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
manager the vote is 10 to 0.
i i hate to mention it but um
representative emerick you said item 371
and it's actually item 389. my apologies
3.89 you're correct okay
uh too much paperwork on a vote of 10 to
21 389 10 to zero
uh
fis
21 389 passes
and i thank you all for uh
coming back and
providing the additional information
that you did to help us make a decision
so
okay
um
maybe we could stand for a moment
maybe five minutes and uh before we
head on to our
annual comprehensive financial report
briefing
just
give us a little
get rid of all those is that a
five-minute recess
yeah something
goodbye
charlie
hang around the corner
[Music]
um
that's going to solve a lot of our
problems
my fear is that
okay
welcome all uh i'm glad you uh
had an opportunity to uh sit through our
uh tabled items
i'm on
and we are
sincerely looking forward to the
annual comprehensive uh
financial report briefing
so
uh
commissioner arlinghaus
i'll kick it off madam chair good
morning members of the committee for the
record steve smith uh lba audit director
and uh as you know we retained kpmg to
do the state audit and joining us from
kpmg is brock romano the partner and
karen farrell who is the manager on the
engagement this year
and then from the department of
administrative services who actually
prepares the report
um commission arlinghaus and our state
comptroller dana call
so with that i will turn it over to
brock and karen and they can actually
present their their opinion and the
results of the audit
thank you steve
um uh good morning uh madam chair
members of the committee uh it's good to
to be back uh in in person again
and uh i'm glad uh madam chair you
mentioned uh this as a briefing because
our our intent is to purposely be high
level
given you know the ocean of information
that's contained in a 162 page document
we're prepared and happy to go into
whatever level of detail the committee
would like
but initially we'd like to make just
some general high-level comments and
then
and then uh management uh will kind of
uh drill a little deeper into a couple
elements of the report but
that that is background so uh when
whenever um i meet with a governing body
to discuss the um
report i'd like to give a little bit of
an overview of what kpmg is doing so
just just as a refresher
kpmg
does the audit of the annual
comprehensive financial statement which
we're going to discuss uh today
uh in in conjunction with that we are
that audit we also
issue a report on internal controls over
financial reporting i believe that's
also in your package and we'll touch
briefly on that as well
that's mean it shouldn't be
and if i were smart i'd know how to fix
this thing
hang up on him
my apologies i'm out of practice as i've
admitted before
so uh
also kpmg
new hampshire uh hires us to do the
separate audit of the turnpike and that
will be presented next week to the
fiscal committee
and then of course we also do an audit
uh of the state's federal programs and
that's something we would present to
this committee uh later on this winter
early spring time
so with that just getting into uh the
annual comprehensive financial
statements and again the headline for us
is the audit opinion i like to remind
committee members in this 160 page
document there's one page that belongs
to us and that's our opinion uh the rest
of it belongs to management and and the
headline there is is that uh we we are
rendering unmodified opinions on the
contents of the annual comprehensive
financial statements so we do our ride
it in a couple of uh in accordance with
professional standards both from the
aicpa as well as government auditing
standards because you do receive
federal funding and that's where we get
that byproduct report on internal
controls as well
in terms of in terms of other items in
the report uh the other opinion that
might be of notice this year the
the state adopted a new uh
government accounting standard board
pronouncement
on fiduciary activities uh we noted it
not in our opinion but for members of
the committee it really was not as
impactful as maybe some other standards
has been in the past so uh we won't get
into too much detail on that and then of
course we also um perform limited
procedures on some of the supplemental
information included in the report
particularly over the
uh budget and
statements that are in the back of the
report as well as
the supplementary information on the
status of your pension and open plans
which which is a personal favorite of
mine and if there's questions on there
be happy to entertain them
um i'm gonna i'm gonna move uh uh off of
the audit opinion for a minute and just
briefly mention that separate report on
internal controls over financial
reporting we have one item in there uh
uh we have uh been reporting the same
item for the last couple years
um uh related to the credit carryovers i
think that's a topic that we've
discussed at length
uh at previous committee uh meetings
happy to go into detail today if the
committee would like i i think the point
here is that uh
there is new hampshire is not unique
most of your
businesses are
making estimated payments and as of a
point in time
they are typically in a
overpaid position
meaning they've they've paid more taxes
and ultimately their returns are
required
and then there's an accounting mechanism
to determine uh whether you should
recognize all of that as revenue or
retain a portion as
either unearned revenue or due back to
the taxpayer and so there's an academic
exercise that we go through with dra
and uh i think the good news is that
number has kind of stabilized around 60
million dollars for the last couple
years but it is it is something that uh
we've been discussing with management um
and and is
that that is the sole item in our uh
separate report on internal controls
so i'm going to pause here for a minute
because i'll go on forever and i'll ask
karen farrell to kind of jump in and
maybe go through some of the required
communications
uh that we typically go over when we
meet with a governing body i will warn
you in advance that you are likely to
hear this again when kpmg shows up next
week to do
the turnpike presentation but i do think
uh it's it's important for us to to make
sure we communicate to you those items
that are significant
uh as it relates to our audit so with
that i'm gonna turn it over to karen
thanks brock you think this one works
i'm sorry uh representative edwards has
a question on the um
credit carryover yes yes so i was just a
finance major because gaap scared me
but uh
it says in in the
supplemental report
that um
we think our best estimate is about 64
million dollars in that neighborhood
is is money that taxpayers
aren't
necessarily going to aren't expected to
apply to future
tax payments
then it says that 64 million is not
considered to be a liability and without
getting into the green eye shades thing
i it it feels like a liability to me and
i'm just curious why um just management
judgment whether or not it's required by
some
rule
why we wouldn't just carry it as a
liability if we think it really is yeah
i might just make one comment and then
let and turn it over to
uh management
and maybe just to to put a finer point
on it
so that
most of your most of your taxpayers are
calendar-based organizations and so they
are paying taxes based on a tax year
and
most taxpayers who make estimated
payments me being one of them in my own
personal life
uh oftentimes will will overpay with the
knowledge that it would be applied to
the next quarterly payment
and so what happens is uh as of the tax
reporting year there's they have made an
overpayment
and then there's an analysis to done
then there's a separate analysis done to
see how much of that overpayment would
have been earned by the state by the end
of your fiscal year
there are different points in time
so
uh i would say that the taxpayers intent
is to leave that money on deposit to be
used for
for future taxes it just happens to
cross fiscal years so the accounting
mechanism that we're highlighting
is that
there's an estimate
of 64 million dollars that really
applies to the next fiscal year
and and
uh it's quite common every every uh
state that i'm aware of kind of runs
into this situation the question is
should you should you record that money
as revenue uh
as of today or should you kind of
report that revenue in the next fiscal
period when it technically will be
earned and so
we're probably in a little green eye
shade category so i will pause
um
and maybe invite as a follow-up i i
think maybe you've you've uh shaken me
enough to where i i now reread
the sentence the state however does not
record a cco tax refund liability in its
annual financial statements and the
preceding paragraph left me with the
impression that we thought there was 64
million dollars that would never be
applied to any future
tax payments so i i just misread the
paragraph and sentence
yeah so one of the things that i'm going
to go over is just a few uncorrected
misstatements that we identified and
that is one so i think that you know
just to kind of clarify a little when i
get to that point is that um you know i
think kpmg believes it should be a
liability as of june 30th 21 of the 64
million so we kind of include that in
our analysis to see what would be
material and whether we can pass on that
entry not being recorded in the state's
annual financial report and and we got
there with that one entry and then a few
others that i'll mention in a little bit
but you know i think to answer your
question we do kpmg does believe that it
should be a liability that's recorded at
the end of
the fiscal year
each year and that's why it kind of
keeps coming up in our discussions
good morning dana call uh state
comptroller
yes you will uh this issue obviously has
been ongoing for quite a while and uh
we've presented to senate finance in the
past a similar finding so this is a kind
of a repeat finding for us
and we would agree that there is an
accounting determination that's made but
there is also state legislative policy
um
by you folks that uh in it it sort of
conflicts in some scenarios and this is
one of those scenarios because this
would
directly affect general fund surplus so
if we were to record it it would have a
significant effect on the funding that
you all use to create the state budget
so
one that has been one of the uh points
that we've been discussing over the past
several years so i'll let mr rowling
house
so one one of the things this is fun um
one of the things that
we've done over time you know this is
this has been an issue and it becomes an
issue when things when things bump up
and when they bump down and i think i
think probably
two or three major inflection points
over the last
i don't know a dozen years i think
probably the big presentation to fiscal
was probably four or five years ago
before my time technically and i've been
commissioner four and a half years so um
when you consider this um
think of the kafir a bunch of different
ways one is that it's an accounting
document it's a state's major accounting
document it's our books
it's also a transparency document and an
accountability document
and and one of the things that's very
important from a state standpoint is
that we don't change
how we account for things we don't
change what we do constantly so as to
confuse anybody trying to look at it
if somebody wants to look at the state's
finances and see how we're doing they
want to look at look at what we do it's
important that there be consistency over
time to the extent that there can be
we do make changes when when gasby
whoever gatsby actually is some obscure
board hiding in connecticut but
pronounces you know gatsby 80 and you'll
have these discussions you know usb 78
is going to make us change everything
and it's opeb calculations a lot of
those calculations have to do with how
the state's books look
are we are we carrying a 1.9
billion dollar opeb liability or is a
2.1 and what are the components of that
and you know functionally from a
practical decision-making standpoint um
those aren't really that different even
though it sounds like a lot of money
um
we've been doing this the same way
for for decades from time immemorial um
probably to the the the origin of the uh
business profits tax um
and um to change it would make a sudden
budget change most of the accounting
decisions we make do not suddenly take
60 or 70 million dollars
off the books and remove them from your
ability to spend them or balance the
books with them
and if we made a dramatic change one of
the reasons to not make a change is
because it looks different
and it and it makes things less
comparable another is that we would
suddenly say 65 million dollars that you
you probably have and you should have
and you probably will have because this
averages out and washes out in the end
suddenly you don't and by the way
dear fiscal committee could you write a
check
um
this happens to be a year when you
when you're awash with money but it's
very rare that that's the case so it it
seemed like an obvious decision to not
um book it that way even though
um
even though kpmg thinks we should
yeah and maybe i'll just make the last
couple of points on this topic
so the opinion that i mentioned earlier
on that we you know our opinion is your
financial statements present fairly
contemplates this topic so so we still
believe your financial statements
are presented fairly including this
topic of discussion
the other point i would make is even
though we we refer to it as a liability
these funds are available to you it's
just the timing of when you would
recognize them so if you wanted to
substitute unearned revenue
as a as a proxy for accounts payable
because we're not suggesting you write a
check necessarily back to the taxpayer
this is really just an accounting
mechanism of when do you record that
revenue the funds will be available for
you
right because you have them they're in
your possession that they can be spent
so the cash flow
none of this is affecting the cash flow
it's just it's just affecting the timing
of recording uh
a tax revenue
and i'll probably stop there because
eyes will glaze over if we've if we've
kind of gone into too much minutia but
um
i i would just add uh to that that
while we have been talking about this
for years we have made some headway uh
you'll see in the response the
management response to the finding that
the legislature has chosen to take a
look at analyzing the credit carry over
liability and putting caps on it and i'm
a member of that commission should it
ever
start
but there is legislation in play and
that has passed that is taking a look at
that so it's not that we're not we're
not ignoring the issue and we've been
actively working with the legislature to
explain the issue with the department of
revenue uh and try to address it at
least from a high level going forward
because it is a large number thank you
we're going to move on
to some more mundane topics um okay so
for the record my name is karen farrell
and as brock mentioned under aicpa
auditing standards we're required to
communicate certain items to those
charged with governance which is
yourselves so the first one being that
we do not identify any significant
unusual transactions it's a little bit
better
while performing the audit
management and compiling their annual
financial statements needs to make
judgments about accounting estimates
like the tax receivables or the opeb
obligation and we deem these to be
reasonable in all material respects
in relation to the financial statements
uh we did not have any disagreements
with management or any scope limitations
in completing our audit
as far as we are aware the state did not
seek out other
auditors opinions on the application of
generally accepted accounting principles
we did not have any major issues that we
discussed prior to being retained as
auditors for the state
we received full cooperation from the
state with management all the way down
to staff really at every level and
completing our audit
we are required to confirm that we are
independent accountants with respect to
the state under all relevant
professional and regulatory guidelines
we did not identify actual a suspected
fraud involving management or any
employees that were in significant
positions of internal control
and no fraud resulted in a material
misstatement in the financial statements
we did not identify material
non-compliance with laws and regulations
and then lastly in addition to the cco
liability we just talked about we did
identify two other
audit differences that weren't corrected
in the annual financial statements
all of these audit differences
individually in the aggregate did not
preclude us from providing an unmodified
opinion
but the second one was
in the prior year there was about 36 and
a half million of personal protective
equipment that was recorded in the
coronavirus relief fund in 21 that was
deemed to be reimbursable by fema so for
us to kind of analyze that transaction
being in a different period we proposed
an entry to push those expenses back to
the general fund just so we could
analyze the effect on the beginning
equity
and then the second one was a reversal
of the unemployment fund receivables
that were booked in contemplation of
kiers
fund transfer that really wasn't
recognizable as of june 30th 21.
and that was approximately 10 million
dollars
and those are the required
communications that we need to go
through
if there's any questions with that
i would just say that if anybody has
any handle on cares funds arpa funds
who who else funds
i
thank you
i would if it's all right i would just
like to add that the i want to thank my
staff obviously and kpmg for another
successful audit 100 remote again for
the second time ever um my staff's in
the office but kpmg folks are remote so
it was um it was another smooth audit
and as well uh thank you lba for their
help because they provide a lot of the
staffing assistance so we work well
together as a team
um i can take a few minutes to
highlight a few things in the book if
you'd like
there's interest
just a couple
okay uh uh just a couple just a couple
yeah no okay
so again it's 160 page book there's a
lot of uh work involved but i'll bring
up a couple of the areas we tend to
discuss the most is page 8
is where you'll find the general and
education
trust fund surplus statements
that is not an audit document so that's
purely on
commissioner and i to prepare
but it does align with our audited
financial statements so
you will see that it reflects a very
healthy year in unrestricted revenue and
a very healthy rainy day fund balance
that is now up to
257.8 million dollars so that is where
we ended the year
um that means because it's the end of uh
the biennium the general fund does not
carry over any unrestricted undesignated
fund surplus that is now all in the
rainy day fund per statute so
um we start anew going into fy 22 but
halfway through the year we're already
in good shape so
um yeah and then if there are no
questions on that i would turn you to
page 28 and 29 is our primary financial
statement where you see the items that
commissioner arlington has discussed in
terms of opeb
pension
debt all of our long-term
this is our balance sheet
this is our long-term
assets and liabilities
nothing really has changed since last
year so that's good news
and then lastly i would turn you to the
general fund statements which is on page
33.
general education highway and the
coronavirus relief fund are reflected
here and their fund balances are here
which is similar to what you would see
in the surplus statement
but this is gap-based and
one thing i would point out the
coronavirus relief fund we typically
don't put federal funds into their own
column federal funds which we've
received you know for years and will
continue to receive for years run its
course through the general fund um but
with when the chrono for iris relief
fund came along the 1.25 billion that
the state received we thought it was
warranted to be highlighted
um unbeknownst to us we've now continued
to receive the same level of funding in
terms of the arpa fund so um we will be
we'll be this column will have an end
life to it
and then we will continue our past
practice of
having the federal funds shown through
the general fund reporting um but that
will be
there's a
variety of other places where arpa funds
are reported including our transparency
website so we'll be talking about that
more in the in the next audit
so those are the highlights
uh yes
represent edwards
thank you madam chairman
it seems like it's been two years maybe
it's been three
but um
boys and means used to have somebody
from the state a very senior guy he's
retired and been re replaced but but one
of the things he would uh talk to ways
and means about is how the financial
analysts were viewing new hampshire's
books
and particularly the rainy day fund
and how that
could potentially influence our bond
rating and so i'm
has this 257 million dollar rainy day
fund has that had any influence uh with
the analysts to either raise or maintain
our bond rating and remind us what the
bond rating is
uh i couldn't well actually i probably
could find it in there but um our
department of treasury so monica
mezapelli is in charge of the bond
issuances and what i can tell you is
that we are issuing
starting that process this month
so in the next couple of months they'll
be issuing bonds and going through the
rating agency process
so
stay tuned i guess is the short answer
because we will find out if that had any
implication on our um current bond
rating which i think is a
a
i'll let back
i'll get i'll get that number
each agency has a different rating
system our bond rating is not the
absolute highest but it's close it's not
been lowered in a long time it was
lowered at one time because the rainy
day fund went through significant
depletion
of the state's balances in general in a
period
running through the last recession
the rainy day fund has never ever been
this high
and and that will lead to very good
things for the bond rating i i don't
want to predict and i don't think monica
would predict
that they will go up
but bond rating agencies will go that's
great
or words to that effect
it's hard not to it's i mean it's it's
astonishingly
i'm going to look at senator
d'alessandro and i probably he doesn't
even remember it being this high ever
yeah
and oh by the way we're making
giant progress in
fy2022 thank you to steve he found it on
page 26. it's a triple a double a plus
for uh fitch
a a one for moody's and double a for s p
representative emerick yes thank you
madam chair
one of when you talked about the arpa
funds and
there's another
one called the governor's office of
emergency relief and recovery is that is
that under this umbrella or is that
being accounted for somewhere else
so the governor's office uh the gopher
office uh
is
reflected they're managing the funds in
the coronavirus relief fund column so
the original 1.25 billion that we
received is being managed by that group
and that is
winding down so as of the end of uh
calendar 21 we were supposed to have
encumbered all of that funding so it'll
take us some time to trickle out
the all of the other funding is
that's why it's different in that at the
time we were working under emergency
orders so the funding and the acceptance
of the funds and the spending of the
fund was going through an entirely
different process the arpa funds are all
going through the normal this process
so anything that's being added to the
budget is coming through this the normal
mechanism um which is you folks
and that is all
going to be accounted for within the
agencies that received the fund
so if health and human services receives
that federal grant it comes through
their portion of the general fund if
environmental services receives funding
it comes through their portion of the
general fund so it will be reflected it
will just make our base numbers that
much higher but it's not
some of it may
be managed by the gopher office but it
will still fall in line with whatever
category of government is spending those
funds
commissioner did you want to add
anything
no
senator guida did you have a question
thank you madam chair
in that we're discussing arpa and kara's
act funds and such
i would like to seek support from this
body
to require gopher to re report to the
fiscal committee
in the aggregate and specifically how
much money has been received how much
money has been granted and how much
money has been spent
both for cares and and arpa
there's a lot of money a lot of it is
going out fast in places and so forth i
think it would help me and i would hope
that some other member of the committee
would second my motion uh to uh to ask
gopher to provide
such an analysis so with the permission
of the chair i'll move
that gopher be required to present to
the fiscal committee a spreadsheet
detailing the expenditure of funds for
cares act and opera our arpa
act revenues to the state
is there a second i would second that
okay senator d'alessandro
um
yeah i haven't gotten there yet
let me just ask this question
i know you said a spreadsheet but would
it be helpful if they actually came and
spoke
so would you mind amending your emotion
so to request
gopher to come before the fiscal
committee
to explain in detail
how much has been received how much has
been appropriated and how much has been
expended for the cares act and arpa act
revenue is received by the state
well
okay
all right thank you
um
is there any discussion
i i i have a question all right just a
moment okay
rep representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair um
senator guida are you aware uh is the
executive branch
already required to provide us with that
information or because this happened
under the state of emergency it it still
remains
us asking instead of us expecting
constitutionally they're required to get
the approval of the legislature by after
resolve before dispensing any funds
okay
that was violated
i haven't seen any comprehensive report
on
receipt expenditure appropriation and so
forth
and i'm not aware because the process
completely circumvented
cares right right thank you uh the
uh the normal process the constitutional
process of
accepting and then expending revenues
i'm not aware of any such okay
before we continue this discussion thank
you all for coming
and thank you for
the great report okay i mean it's uh
it's a lot of work on the on the part of
das
and
of course we love it when we receive a
uh
what was it called
audit excellence
clean opinion is the generic term we use
oh no no that the certificate that goes
yes we we submit the financial
statements to the gfoa for an award
every year and we did receive it again
yes and that that's
very good so i thank you all if you'd
like to continue or listen to our
discussion you're more than welcome to
stay
but um
probably not
thank you very much
okay i'm sorry to
interrupt that but uh
i thought we should get back to
thank you madam chair i think i think i
heard the answer to be
that um it's not clear
whether we should be expecting it or
whether we're just asking for it correct
is there any other discussion
yes
does the change in motion
preclude
preclude the
presenters
from having available an electronic or
paper copy
of
the information that that senator geider
has asked for
because i that's what i heard in the
original motion was that we would have
some sort of document that we'd be used
to referral
that now has been changed to a verbal
but i would
like to also ensure that there was some
something electronic or
in paper that we'd be able to refer to
my goal was just simply to
enhance the motion
to add
a presentation
it was not to eliminate the
the
spreadsheet
so
safe to say
by consensus of the body that a
spreadsheet will be provided in addition
to a presentation
that's right of that motion yes and that
it be electronic
well
more than likely it can be both but
electronic at least
that's because you have your little
computer sitting there which is totally
against the rules
okay it's in a public hearing
oh
[Music]
okay
is there any other discussion
uh michael
do you have a feel
for
what is going on with um
cares and arpa
i do um
so i know that gopher
has a lot of information on their
website the problem it's not in a uh a
summary format that
i believe will be very helpful for the
legislature so for instance cares you
have 1.25 they have a high level summary
by program type of where it went but how
much has been expended how much i think
that's something the community has so we
can relay that to the commissioner
uh as far as uh our funds are involved
um they did put out a new report gopher
on their website
i just noticed it today
just kind of breakdown of all the fiscal
approvals of the arpa there's about 958
million of flex funds uh black for
better term about 400 million has been
spent and they have it down to a certain
category level i'll send that to the
committee um obviously i don't believe
gopher would be ready to go for your
january 21st meeting plus i think you
have your binders in your office right
now
but i will send you kind of what they
have now and wait for feedback from you
and then communicate this with taylor
and taylor caswell and gopher
to get a report that's going to be
helpful so you can see where that money
went
i know they keep track of it
there's so much money coming in i think
you have to keep track of it is audited
um it's just the reporting part of it
and so
let me pull i'll pull together some
links from gopher that i think may get
you closer to where you want to go and
then i'll wait for your feedback and
i'll include everyone and share that
with taylor caswell so you get a report
and a presentation is what you're
looking for i think there's
a lot of information sometimes it's too
much information nothing against gopher
but if you go to the gopher site there
the time that you have to spend on that
will try to um
minimize okay thank you okay
uh any more discussion
seeing none um
do i have to do a roll call
no okay all those in favor please raise
your hand
oppose none
motion carries 10-0
okay
i know it says
we have to schedule our next fiscal
meeting
we've done that already
it's next friday at 10 o'clock
and as
was just reported for the house
our books are out here yes and the
senate books are in their offices in
their offices oh what a nice service
i i totally agree
all right so um in that case thank you
all for coming
and
i i have a motion to adjourn
d'allesandro senator d'alessandro and
senator guida seconds
all those in favor
are
opposed
i guess i'll just sit here by myself
[Music]
yes
everybody